hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster now if there's one
thing the conservatives don't need it's
more Scandal and this evening Daniel
corski has quit the race to be London
mayor after allegations of groping
meanwhile the government continues to
struggle against High inflation soaring
interest rates and the cost of living
crisis that just won't go away and to
make matters worse the country's biggest
water company supplying a quarter of all
UK households is on the brink of
collapse so plenty for us to get stuck
into as we bring you takes from all
sides over the next 60 minutes
now this is how Daniel corski announced
he was pulling out of that race to be
the Conservative candidate for London
mayor doing so he said with a heavy
heart will have much more reaction this
evening but meanwhile at pmqs earlier
the party leaders clashed over what else
the economy
it's why we've introduced the new
mortgage Charter which by the way goes
much more farther than the labor party
policy on protecting mortgage holders
does
well the Prime Minister Anthony setting
the scene for the kind of arguments we
are going to hear a lot in the year to
come and the labor leader used a phrase
that I think you might hear a bit more
of
a Tory mortgage bombshell because they
crashed the economy Millions left
without support because he won't make
lenders put Families First
well we'll certainly talking about the
cost of living crisis this evening and
lots more with our guests on the show
tonight
we will be joined by the work and
pension secretary Mel stride the shadow
environment secretary Jim McMahon an
awful lot in his brief of course with
Thames water plus we'll talk to the
Canadian defense minister Anita Anand
and much more besides too on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
hello well there's lots going on today
from Thames water to Daniel corski to
what is in many ways the image of the
day the just stop oil protesters running
onto the pitch during the ashes at Lords
but there's been plenty more going on
during the week so far not least of
course the covert inquiry with Matt
Hancock giving evidence for the first
time so let's crack straight on and
start with the best bits of the week so
far
the former Health secretary Matt Hancock
has given an emotional apology the
inquiry into the covid-19 pandemic Mr
Hancock's continuing to give evidence
this morning it comes after the wife of
one covert victim broke down in tears
outside the inquiry I was assured that
the UK planning
was
among the best and in some instances the
best in the world the government has
begun drawing up contingency plans for
the collapse of Thames water amid
growing doubts in Whitehall about the
ability of Britain's biggest water
company to service its 14 billion pound
debt pile it's all this comes amid a
growing debate about the merits of a
privatized water industry with many of
its critics arguing that some form of
mutual public ownership would deliver
more reliable and efficient services to
the public sources are tells guy news
the conservative party will not
investigate a sexual assault allegation
leveled at the London mayoral hopeful
Daniel corski a spokesperson for Mr
corski gave us the following statement
it says in the strongest possible terms
Dan categorically denies any allegation
of inappropriate behavior whatsoever
Daniel corski has dropped out of the
race to become the Conservative
candidate in the London mayoral elect
action following a claim that he grouped
a TV producer in Downing Street he says
the news agenda essentially these
allegations against him have become a
distraction from his campaign three
people have been arrested after just
stop oil protesters invaded the pitch at
laws just moments after the start of the
second ashes test match between England
and Australia one of the protesters was
carried off the field you can see there
by England wicketkeeper Johnny bairstow
how many will have to lose their homes
Before He'll stand up for the people his
party have pushed into economic misery
Mr Speaker if at the vast majority of
the mortgage Market is now covered by
the new mortgage Charter that the chance
has brought in
at that image of Johnny depasto carrying
physically the just stop oil protester
off the pitch that's one that will stick
in everyone's mind I'm sure well let's
get some reaction from the government
now shall we on the state of Thames
water and much more a little earlier I
spoke to the work on pensioner secretary
Mel strides but
typical timing of course it was just
before we heard that Daniel korski had
dropped out of the race due to the
allegation so do bear that in mind when
you watch this interview don't worry we
will bring you up to date after it here
is Mel stride
just talk us through what is the latest
with Thames water well I can't really
comment for example the financial
position of a private company and you
wouldn't expect me to but what I can
reassure you and your viewers of is that
whatever happens or transpires over the
coming weeks and months the water will
continue to flow the government and off
what have contingency measures for
exactly the kind of circumstances that
may play out here yet to be seen and
that's basically where we are with it I
mean one of those is temporary public
ownership right
um I mean somewhat argue that permanent
nationalization could be the way forward
anyway well as I say I certainly don't
want to start speculating on those kind
of issues we've got to really see where
thing how things develop but what I can
reassure you of is that we absolutely
have contingency plans in place for any
eventuality you can see why people
angry though right
who was it going up so we're just going
into the sea and yet water companies
paid out 1.4 billion pounds in dividends
last year that's up from 540 million the
last year well um the government working
through off what actually is put in uh
to affect uh new regulations which make
sure that when it comes to dividends and
indeed bonuses paid Within These
companies that they relate to things
that are not about environmental damage
so I think that's a very important point
and of course we do have a plan 56
billion pounds worth of investment going
forward to make sure that we reduce the
sewage outflows now an important Point
here Sophie is if you went back to 2010
less than 10 percent of those outflows
were being monitored so we didn't
actually know what the situation was at
that point by the end of this year it'll
be about it we know so we've got greater
transparency and we've got a plan to
deal with it as well look look the
sewage into the sea is one aspect of the
bits The Wider point is people will look
at the water pump companies and they'll
be thinking
um this isn't working why don't we
nationalize them you know they were
privatized in 1989 since then household
builds up 40 it paid out 66 billion
pounds in dividends to shareholders no
wonder that 63 of Voters think they
should be privatized well as I say I'm
not going to get into whether we should
be wholesale you know renationalization
that is not our policy the important
thing that we need to do is to make sure
we get the incentives properly aligned
within those companies and I've just
explained how through off what we're
doing that how we also invest the right
amount of money going forward to make
sure that we get on top of these sewage
outflow issues and that's what we're
absolutely determined to do
you know I do not have any concerns in a
way out the way that Thames water is run
well as I say it just wouldn't be right
for me to start commenting on a
situation in a private company which may
or may not be a Compares
yes
absolutely absolutely should be
commenting on this in fact since
privatization uh the the the number of
occasions on which people who experience
a lack award coming out of the town has
reduced by over 80 so a lot of progress
has been made as I say it's very
concerned the important thing well I I'm
concerned that there is resilience in
terms of delivery within that sector but
I'm equally satisfied that the
government and off what have the
appropriate contingencies in place such
that whatever May materialize over the
coming days weeks and months and I'm not
going to speculate on that because I
don't think it'd be right to do so that
we will be in a position where water
still flows out of the Taps and
everybody gets the supply that they
expect and want okay yeah I guess it
it adds to a wider concern that people
have about the economy that times are
really really difficult at the minute
you know you've got the cost of living
going up you've got mortgage bills
spiraling and there is a suspicion that
this is partly of course not holy but
partly because firms aren't doing the
right thing and I just want to show you
this from the international monetary
fund you know they're hardly you know
kind of woke left parade but they say
that corporate profits now account for
nearly half of all Euro area inflation
that the red bars you can see there
going up yeah corporate profits what
would you say to that well I think we
take that kind of data I know the bank
of England does as well very seriously
so the chancellor has uh just this
morning I think met with the competition
markets Authority who are looking into
for example unit pricing across the
retail sector particularly with the
focus on food where we have for example
seen in countries like Germany and
Portugal and Sweden food inflation up at
around 20 it's a bit over 14 in our
country but it's still high so we're
certainly looking at that where we see
super normal profits due to Big external
shops like rides it raises in the energy
prices that we've gone in and we've had
windfall taxes which we've used in the
case of energy companies to make sure
that we have halved the average Energy
bill tax over the last year so what sort
of energy sector then well I I'm not
going to speculate as to on taxation
policy that's a matter for the
chancellor but I think to your point
about excessive profits where we saw it
within the energy sector we stepped
indecisively we did apply additional
taxes in that particular case windfall
taxes which we then use to lower
people's fuel bills energy bills and I
think that that was the right thing to
do and potentially could be the right
thing I really do want to speculate
you've been very very well behaved on on
the on the interview and but do you have
concerns about
excess profits in other sectors other
than engine well as I say I think the
competition markets Authority are in
discussions with the chancellor it is
something that the bank of England and
others are looking at what government
can't and in my opinion shouldn't be
doing is attempting to from the ministry
at the center try and control pricing
across the whole of the economy that's
just not realistic the important thing
is you rely generally on competition to
make sure that margins are at sensible
levels but as I say particularly in the
case of retail and food the chancellor
has been working and liaising very
closely with the competition of markets
Authority there is an ongoing
investigation going on at the moment
they're looking closely at that and I
think that's the right approach and
we've been talking about the cost of
living and how difficult it is for
people and I guess there is nowhere
where that is more acute than child care
like it takes a huge proportion of
people's monthly incomes yeah what are
you doing so from today we have
increased very substantially in fact by
47 the maximum amount that those on
Universal Credit can claim against their
child care so a huge increase in the
amount of support that's going in there
the second thing we've done is one of
the barriers to people taking on child
care has been they've had to find the
money up front for that first month and
we're providing financial assistance to
take that problem away but you mentioned
the cost of living so if you're in your
right to do so my department has been
right at the center of getting out those
cost of living payments to 8 million
low-income households 900 pounds 150
pounds to 6 million disabled people 300
pounds in December to those who are
pensioners we mentioned the energy price
guarantee keeping those energy costs
down I put up the benefits generally by
10.1 percent pensions went up by 10.1
the national living wage for the low
paid by 9.7 wherever we can Target those
who are most vulnerable and most in need
that is where we're providing that vital
support now all a little bit about the
race to be London there and I'm sure
this won't come is a new surprise to you
um Daniel korski now he of course is one
of the final three in the running to be
the Conservative candidate to be London
mayor he's been accused of groping
somebody touching their breasts he
denies it should he withdraw
well it's not for me I think to opine
all that I've read what I've read in the
papers I don't know the background to
the situation uh I know that a complaint
has been made uh but what I do know is
where complaints have been made they
will be looked into very thoroughly uh
he of course has vigorously denied the
allegations that have been made
um but I I don't I don't know the the
realities of that situation how
important is it for this complaint to be
investigated quickly I think any serious
complaint of that nature clearly needs
to be looked at who should invest
everything well this it would be
determined by I think the nature of the
complaint and if I can talk in
generalities we know what the complaint
is right well the allegation is well I I
personally you may know more than me I
don't know the full details and and you
do need to look into complaints in
details to determine for example whether
it's a matter of the police or is not
about it for the police and I'm not
sitting here today in your Studio
knowing the answer to that so I think
the important thing is that to know that
it will be looked into appropriately
whereas
this guy is in the running speed the
London mayor it feels like it depends it
depends on it right so where there's a
formal complaint that's made
um it could be anybody that's made a
formal complaint about anybody else and
that kind of situation it's then down to
the judgments of those where the
complaints be made as to where that goes
on to now does it does it become
something that the police should be
looking at is it something that's an
internal process within a political
party and so on but what I'm saying is
I'm not in a position and probably you
aren't either with great respect to be
able to determine who exactly should be
looking into the complaints of that
nature
details you who the complaint would be
to be completely it's the reason I'm
asking this is because the woman who's
made this allegation says that it wasn't
actually that easy to raise a complaint
yes and those around Daniel Corsica were
saying well they're no complaints being
made she's like okay then I will try and
make a complaint yeah and and I just I
don't know who's going to look into that
well I'm not saying that I should decide
who listen to it if I'm saying that I
guess maybe people would have a bit more
confidence in the process that you say
should be followed if we knew what that
process was so I think in any situation
where there is a complainant uh
involving somebody that is serious in
the first instance it really depends on
exactly what the nature of that
complaint is as to where they go so in
this case there is a political Dimension
to it so
um I I believe there is a complaint to
government but as to where it finally
gets investigated is if that is what is
appropriate then I think it does depend
on the precise nature and the details of
exactly what happened okay or is alleged
to have happened and I don't feel in a
position to sit here and say Sophie this
is how it should happen this is who
should investigate it or these should be
the consequences sure sure I'm not
asking you to decide I just wonder who
would no no or exactly how it should be
proceed who are you supporting in the
race to be London I haven't decided I I
want to see you know who I want to see a
bit more of them um but uh I've I've not
decided at this stage I'm Claire catino
said today that her support for Daniel
corski is on pause right now well as I
say I I haven't made a decision as to
who I would like to see in that position
okay there's one more thing that I do
want to get your view on as well this
happened at the ashes earlier today
Johnny Bear stayed there uh England
cricketer yes carrying off a just stop
oil protester
what do you make of this do you think
it's fair enough that people want to you
know make a protest in a non-violent way
yeah I believe believe in a free society
in which people's voice voices should be
heard and I believe in protest I don't
believe in that and I don't believe in
people going to the Chelsea flower show
and throwing things around I don't
believe in people sitting in the road
and holding up the traffic and stopping
ambulances and inconveniencing the
general dollar
approach of carrying them well we've
given them the tools to be fairly robust
in those situations and I think
generally speaking the police should be
fairly robust
um and I don't think it helps their
calls I think that's the irony of all
this I think most people look at that
and just think that it's the wrong way
to go about protesting okay thank you
very much thank you
well of course since that interview
Daniel corski pulled out the race which
meant maester I didn't have to comment
on it but we weren't going to let him
get away with that were we because after
we heard the news about the uh pulling
out of the race our producer Izzy loss
of put on her best running shoes she
managed to get a camera in front of him
out on the street by the studio here as
he was leaving and this is what he said
I think probably the the political
pressure here is such that he's probably
taken the right decision but it's not
for me to opine as to whether the
allegations are right or wrong I know he
denies them but I think probably the
political pressure made that the right
thing and as he said in his statement I
think the pressure that he's putting on
his family
there well we are going to talk more
about Daniel corski on the program later
on
um but I just want to get a bit of
reaction to I guess some bigger picture
stuff with Sam our Deputy political
editor at some coaches with us now
there's an awful lot of pressure going
on with cost of living there's a little
awful lot of scrutiny going on about how
much government should intervene in
markets and companies to help people and
now of course we have this Thames water
story first broken by our city editor
Mark Kleinman
it does really feel like something is
going on in politics right now
that's right you know it might seem like
there are just a lot of disparate things
going on but but there is a big theme
that links them at the moment which is
whether you're looking at the
government's attempts to bring down
prices whether you're looking at the
government talking to the regulator
about whether or not to bring Thames
water back into National leadership
temporarily to keep it together to keep
it keep it functioning you're having to
watch conservative struggle with as it
were what you always thought
conservative ideology was and it was
really interesting listening to Mel
strides in that interview because you
were effectively asking him about the
limits of the free market and where the
state should intervene whether it's on
Energy prices whether it's on the Water
System whether it's on uh prices all
around today Jeremy Hunt had a meeting
with five Regulators he claimed that
he'd got an action plan off the back of
that in order to bring down prices all
sorts of areas ensure that Banks pass on
savings through interest rates to their
customers persuade petrol pet stations
to bring down costs as the international
oil price comes down but in the end
what's going on at the moment is markets
aren't able to regulate themselves and
conservatives of having to find whether
or not they need to intervene heavily
they're finding that difficult yeah I
got that sense from male stride too you
can tell that he is someone who believes
in free markets right he's a capitalist
and I just got the sense that he he was
so uncomfortable criticizing business
but I guess if you are kind of poor the
thread that they seem to be suggesting
we should which is that yes there are
excess profits being made that certainly
seems to be what the chancellors wrote
about and there has to be some kind of
control right
and what's really striking is the
language that they use there's a there's
a bit of a cop-out going on today
ministers will confirm that they are
involved in talks about nationalizing
Thames water they're looking at um
various plans across various bits of the
economy but if you want off them in
interviews their default is to hide
behind Regulators they're saying talk to
off walk talk to the competition and
markets Authority talk to uh the
financial conductivity they're the
people that do the dirty business of
intervening in markets and we set some
principles but no right now the Tories
are discovering four political reasons
the limit to the free market having to
recalibrate the kind of Grand Vision
speeches that they spent 20 years going
on about and actually work rework out
for themselves where sensible limits to
free markets should lie and it's not
where they told us it was that's really
interesting Sam a big kind of philosophy
philosophical questions uh tonight we'll
have more from Sam later in the program
we'll also hear from labor as well their
position is quite interesting I think in
The Wider context of what me and Sam
were talking about too under German
Corbin you knew that that was an
opposition very happy to talk about
intervening in markets what about care
starman's shutter cabinet we'll find out
after the break live here in Westminster
[Music]
about his position
on Thames water
[Music]
hello welcome back to Westminster you're
watching the take
Serge in rivers and on beaches worries
about the cost of water and profits made
by firms and now the country's biggest
water company supplying fully a quarter
of the population Thames water is on the
brink of collapse we'll know better
labor front bencher to talk to us this
evening than the shadow environment
secretary this is Jim McMahon
lots of concern over the future of
Thames water how worried should we be
well I think it is a worry you know the
largest water company in Britain it's
got deaths of 14 billion pounds that are
built up uh it's got millions of people
who rely on it for its clean water for
this for dealing with the uh the sewage
and you know rightly people are
concerned about what that means in
particular if it requires a
government-led bailout that's then
ultimately added to the bill payers and
so we've been holding the government to
account we brought today an urgent
question to Parliament the Secretary of
State it didn't even bother to turn up
to answer the question and so you know
for me it does raise kind of real
concerns about whether the government
have got a grip on this or whether
they've been taken by complete surprise
because they haven't organized well
enough so what needs to happen then what
should happen well the question for the
government really is is this the canary
in the coal mine is this really speaking
to a wider vulnerability in our water
industry where 72 billion pounds has
been taken out in shareholder dividends
we haven't seen money invested to reduce
leaks and sewage discharges what should
happen though that's the question well
right now Thames water lots of people be
very worried if you are in government
what would you do well this point the
regulator has the power to have a court
order to essentially take control of the
water company to make sure they continue
to trade and service its customers and
we understand those thoughts are taking
place today if we were in government
well you would expect me to say we
wouldn't be here in the first place
because we are not surprised by this you
know we've had the warnings of financial
vulnerability from off what themselves
who have said oh but two of the water
companies in England and Wales are above
the debt levels that they're comfortable
with that they agreed to in the last
price review and It just strikes me that
we haven't got the right balance here
we've allowed those shareholder
dividends to go out on one hand 72
billion pound we've allowed debt now to
reach levels of 60 billion pound that
we're all paying for for our bills and
now we're requiring forward investment
to deal with the water shortages where
leaks are losing water and also sewage
discharges where our rivers lakes and
seas are being completely disrespected
we're all human sewage well you've
spelled out the problem right yeah does
that mean that labor would bring the
water companies back under government
control would you nationalize them well
we said as a point so this is for the
industry overall taking to one side of
the issue immediately with terms which
is as a point of principle why should
working people pay twice they've already
paid through their bills for water
companies would labor nationalize the
water companies we believe that the
water companies they've taken 72 billion
pound of shareholder dividends should be
made to fix a system that's broken would
labor nationalize award companies well
the answer is no because the water
companies have to put right to the
system that they've taken 72. I'll be
honest I think there'll be an awful lot
of people listening to you thinking I
agree with you these Dividends are
ridiculous look at this 1.4 billion
pounds in dividends the water companies
last year that's outrageous sewage in
the rivers and the Seas that is
outrageous as well and of course now
these Financial vulnerabilities as well
why won't you nationalize them well at
this point why should bill pay us
because that's who would pay you the
bill of nationalization why should Bill
payers pay water company shareholders
who have already taken over 70 billion
pound out of the system why should they
pay them for an artificial inflation
they could uh
is better water and cheap in the long
term I guess but I think that's about
regulation in the end and we can require
instead of losing that 1.8 to 2 billion
pound every single year in dividend
payments as an average we can direct
water companies to use that to fix a
sewage Scandal to fix the leaks where
we're having water shortages that's got
to be the first protocol before we go to
nationalization now clearly we have to
deal with all eventualities and if we
have a system a water industry that has
market failure we're not seeing that on
a systemic level yet but we are
concerned about Thames then of course
you need to look at that environment at
that point in time but that's not where
we are today what about the regulator of
what has that failed well it's pretty
clear that the regulator has very big
questions to answer but in the end the
regulator will only ever be as strong as
a government gives it direction to be
strong and gives it the powers to be
strong and I observe frankly a secretary
of state and a conservative government
that haven't given it the importance
that's needed haven't given it the
strength of ambition that's needed and
haven't given them the powers that's
needed to put this right so absolutely
they can do more but it requires
leadership from the conservative
government to really give them the
direction
um now the times have just published a
story in the last hour or so to say that
case Dharma is planning to reshuffle his
top team in the next month or so I just
want to read a quote to you from the
piece and the quote is Jim McMahon is
likely to be demoted from Shadow
environment secretary with labor
determined to do more about water
cleanliness
doesn't sound great for you uh well I
mean listen first of all that's
speculation and I'm very proud of the
word that I've done in the environment
brief you know the way that we have
really brought now to the Public's
attention what's really been going on
here's Diamond might be listening but I
I'm pretty confident that I've done a
good job on water that I've done a good
job on access uh to Nature that we've
done a good good job on food security
now clearly I'm not going to speculate
about a future reshuffle but I can say
in terms of my record in the post that
I'm very proud of what I've done and I
would just say this how many people had
it in their Consciousness that raw human
sewage was being dumped in their Rivers
their Lakes and their Seas of course
because of the campaigners but also
because the way that labor has given
from the front bench and I've LED from
the front on that in a way that I'm very
proud of because I believe in the end it
comes down to what does it mean to live
a decent fulfilled Life as a working
person and having quality of life is
really important to that so speculating
to one side I'm very proud of what I do
in this job I mean
I mean this in the nice little way but
it sounds a little bit like you're
trying you're almost acknowledging that
you are like to lose your job and you're
just trying to pitch film your record
but I'm not for a star and I'm not going
to get into the speculation and the
motivations uh behind it uh but listen
the environment brief is a coveted brief
and I wouldn't be surprised at all if
more people were looking at it and
saying with the profile that we've
raised in terms of food Security in
terms of the water industry in terms of
Nature and all that has to offer of
course I would expect other people are
coming from you maybe maybe they're who
briefed but I'm very proud of the work
uh that I've done uh and I do think that
is seen by others okay
um are you quick at them and not
particularly no what did you make a
video I think I just battered that one
away hopefully
very good
um what did you make with the uh just of
oil protesters interrupt in the ashes
well I mean I think as a general rule if
we want Everyday People to believe that
the climate crisis is something that
they have to make a contribution to
individually and collectively we've got
to bring people with us and I think any
measures that really set the general
public against the argument isn't
helpful so I can understand why they
feel the need to do it because it gets
attention and we're talking about it
today but I definitely don't believe
that's the way to win the hearts and
minds of the General Public
thank you very much okay
foreign
break just before our interview saying
he was going to be demoted in a
reshuffle in the next month uh maybe
quick at Hasty call to his advisor to
work out the line on that one
interesting stuff though of course as
well from labor on whether or not the
water company should be nationalized
difficult issue at Fordham as well
you're watching the take we are live in
Westminster up next we are going to be
taking a closer look at those
allegations around one of the former
candidates to be London mayor for the
conservatives Daniel Causley
[Music]
hey welcome to Westminster you're
watching the take this evening well
we've been discussing throughout the
program Daniel korski one of the three
in the race to be the Conservative
candidate for mayor of London has
dramatically dropped out of the contest
and this is all about an allegation that
was made against him by a novelist and
TV producer Daisy Goodwin that he
touched her breast in 2013. this is what
we had to say a little bit earlier this
evening
he said I categorically deny the
allegation against me nothing was ever
put to me formally 10 years ago nor
seven years ago when the allegation was
alluded to no investigation has ever
taken place I've been clear I would
welcome and constructively participate
in any investigation however the
pressure on my family because of this
false and unproven allegation and the
inability to get a hearing from my
message of the London dream makes it
impossible for my campaign to carry on
well I want to talk to you our political
correspondent Liz Bates who joins us now
Liz really no one better to talk to you
talk to the new this evening because
you've done a lot looking into how
complaints I looked at in Westminster
about the culture in Westminster whether
victims and alleged victims are able to
get their voices heard
what has this allegation and the way
it's been dealt with what's your
Takeaway on it
what has happened in the last couple of
days with Daniel korsky I think has
shown a light on the problem in
Westminster the difference between the
processes that are in place the codes of
conduct the various bodies that you can
go to to make complaints and culture
within Westminster and sometimes there
is a huge Gulf between those two things
now what's been quite interesting in
particular
um with Daniel korski I think is that
when this allegation emerged what we
were told again and again by the
conservative party and number 10 who
both have a level of responsibility to
in some way deal with this was that the
process room the processes were in place
what has become increasingly clear I
think to me over the last 24 or 48 hours
is there really are no processes in
place to deal with this there was never
in the end a proper investigation
launched and what happened was both of
those institutions stepped back hoped
that it would resolve itself and in the
end it did in a way that how can this be
a good resolution for victims in future
who feel that they have to go to the
press to get anything done or people who
are accused who Daniel kowsky is now
dropped out without any investigation
purely because of the political pressure
that surrounded him it does feel a bit
crazy doesn't it and I was quite struck
by the interview that did with Mel
stride because I kept asking who's going
to investigate and he was like no it's
not up to me to decide that and you
shouldn't be deciding that either but I
guess I was asking because
if there is a process surely you should
be able to say who's going to look at it
even if we don't know the outcome yes
and I thought that again that's the
question that I've been asking this week
to number 10 to the conservative who was
actually looking into it nobody's
looking into it that in the end is the
problem and the reason is because nobody
wanted to look into it nobody felt that
they wanted to step up and take
responsibility and I think the
interesting thing about this as well is
you know you look back the conservative
party already knew of this allegation
and had already chosen to do nothing and
I thought Mel stride's view on it really
encapsulated how conservative MPS feel
how the party feel how many institutions
in Westminster feel they don't want to
deal with it they want it to sort itself
out on its own and you saw melstrid
there saying well maybe it was the right
thing to do to step down and what he
meant was that's the best thing for me
for the party for our future but not for
the people in involved who've really
been through the Ring of both of them
really interesting Liz great to talk and
thank you very much for giving us your
take now we are rattling on in the
program if you are an MP looking
nervously at the next election which I
think quite a lot of them will be you
might be concerned about the boundaries
of your constituency what it means for
your chances adaptive political editor
Sam coats he's Keen to talk a little bit
more about the all-important
constituency boundaries Sam why should
we care about this so it's not that
you'll be reading the enormous amounts
of documentation published today on the
boundary commission website it's because
what do you mean surely our viewers are
going to be absolutely all over the
Internet checking that out what's going
on is that many many constituency
boundaries are being redrawn in order to
make sure that some of them don't get
too big 77
000 is going to be the ceiling really of
how big a constituency is going to be in
the next Parliament and that requires
some redrawing some reallocation so it's
in essence there are going to be fewer
seats in Wales more seats in England but
the reason this is interesting is that
all of a sudden MPS thought that the
area they thought they represent in some
cases doesn't exist anymore or they have
to fight for a new seat to represent and
I think this is going to be the
beginning of something quite difficult
in politics if you just uh pull up what
we've got here
um you've got some um MPS pouring over
Maps like this one now this is Northwest
Durham uh showing uh the constituency of
one uh Rick Holden who is a high-flying
minister one of the few 2019 red wallers
actually to be in Rishi sunat's
government every reason to think that
he's got a bright political future in
front of him apart from this I hope we
can read his statement
which comes after that all the detailed
maps on his wall that he's taken a
picture of uh if we go on to the next
slide we can see uh this which is an
extraordinary statement from him saying
that he is now absolutely deeply
disappointed and frankly devastated that
the boundary commission today uh has
decided that they're getting rid of his
seat and it doesn't look like he at the
moment knows where he's going to stand
or even if he's going to stand now he's
not fully decided to standing down it
but he doesn't look like he's got a
political future now that ties in that
kind of uncertainty for MPS I think it's
going to mean more people announcing
their standing down today we had the
66th MP announcing that they're standing
down that was Stuart Hosey veteran SMP
we've got more than one in 10 MP saying
that they're standing down and quite a
lot of them five of them were first
selected in 2019. oh that is
extraordinary isn't it and it hasn't
haven't really left very long have they
if they decided to go just a few years
after first being elected bad news and
conservatives I guess as well the stats
are Stark 41 Tories are standing down 14
Labor uh of those 25 of the Tories are
elected in 2010 and later they're going
in quite large numbers we're going to
see a very different uh Parliament after
the next election whatever happens you
are watching the take live in
Westminster next up we're going to be
talking about Ukraine
foreign
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take now it's been an
extraordinary last few days in Russia
that attempted Rebellion on Saturday and
then the rumors and the claims that have
followed all as President Putin tries to
reassert his diminished Authority
well meanwhile in Ukraine the war grinds
on with the Ukrainian counter-offensive
seemingly getting into its stride
President zielinski says that progress
is being made and British Military
Intelligence assessments earlier this
week said the ukrainians had likely
taken ground held by Russia since 2014
the first time that happened well Canada
is a key part of the Western Alliance
supplying arms and other AIDS Ukraine
the country's defense minister Anita
Anand is in the UK meeting our defense
secretary Ben Wallace I spoke to her a
little earlier
you've been here in the UK today talking
about Ukraine and what's been discussed
the continuing need for us to support
Ukraine in the short and the long term
as it fights back the Russians we've
seen Ukraine make gains in the North and
the East and the South
and we as a group of countries around
the NATO table will continue to be there
to support Ukraine it's about Ukraine
sovereignty but also the rules-based
international order that has kept us all
safe since the end of the second world
war do you think that Ukraine can
actually win the war most definitely the
resolve of the Ukrainian people is
evident Putin thought he would take
heave in days and he thought that Europe
would freeze in the dark he thought that
the NATO table would fracture all of
those things have not come to pass
Ukraine is continuing to show that it
has the will and the ability to win this
unjust and illegal War we had the
extraordinary week that we saw in Russia
with the attempted Rebellion by the head
of the Wagner group
has that made any difference do you
think to the wall I told my team that we
need to continue to focus on the purpose
of Western and indeed Canadian Aid and
that is to help Ukraine fight and win
this war Canada has already donated over
1 billion dollars of military aid and
over 8 billion dollars of economic
financial and military aid overall and
that's our purpose focusing on how we
can help Ukraine we have a very large
Ukrainian diaspora in Canada and we are
100 with Ukraine so that it can win this
war you say you're 100 with Ukraine how
committed is Canada to Nato
Canada is a founding member of NATO and
we have been a strong partner around the
table we lead the enhanced forward
presence battle group in Latvia for
example and have done so for over five
years so we are very strong and
continuing contributing partner to Nato
with boots on the ground I guess one of
the reasons that I'm asking is because
NATO recently held its largest ever
combat exercise over Germany
Canada didn't go are you committed to
Nato or are you really prepared for
other people I guess to do your dirty
work for you not at all we have
participated in numerous NATO exercises
we recently signed a contract with
Lockheed Martin to purchase 88 f-35s and
we are in a period of growth in our
Royal Canadian Air Force and we are
continuing to undertake that growth
while participating in exercises
wherever we can
um you spent the day with Ben Wallace
the UK defense secretary today he was
hoping to get a new job ahead of NATO
would have you would you like to say
that Ben has been an incredible
collaborator and partner around the NATO
table as well as with the defense
contact group I enjoy working with him
immensely and will continue to do so so
would you made a good at NATO head then
Ben's an incredible leader and I know
that he is very capable at whatever he
does
um
I'm Keen to ask you a bit of a big
picture question now because you know
it's great to have you here we don't
always get the chance to speak to
representatives from other countries in
this way
um we've been talking about Russia and
Ukraine but there are clearly other
Global threats that people have their
eye on for you what would you say is the
biggest Global threat right now
I think that it is a mistake for us to
focus on one conflict Zone alone and
indeed Putin would like nothing more
than to see us all Focus 100 on one
country the country that he illegally
invaded no for us we take a step back
and we say that the global threat
environment has changed overall Canada
recently released for example its
indo-pacific strategy we are committing
as a Pacific country to increase our
presence in the indo-pacific to add a
third frigate to engage in exercises
with our partners to increase our
presence in the area of cyber security
this is just an example of how Canada
won't just focus on one global conflict
Zone we will take a broad-based approach
to ensure that we are fulfilling our
obligations upholding internet national
law as well as International Norms it's
interesting you're talking about cyber
security a lot of people talk about
artificial intelligence as being a way
that is Transforming Our World is that
something that you've got your eye on as
well Canada is a leader in the
artificial intelligence space in the
area of quantum Technologies and
Innovation writ large and we certainly
do have our eye on that in furthering
our relationships with our partners
offering our expertise certainly in the
five eyes context we will continue to
collaborate with our partners in that
Alliance as well as around the NATO and
NORAD tables and one very different
subject I want to ask you about because
I know that it's something that many of
our viewers have been following very
closely which is the fate of the Ocean
Gate submarine where people have
tragically lost their loans when they
were going to try and view the Titanic
now Canadian authorities have been
investigating is there any update you
can give us on that well first and
foremost I'd like to extend my deepest
condolences to the families who lost
loved ones
in that incident my heart really goes
out to them in terms of Canada we have
an investigation that is ongoing that is
being conducted by Transport Canada and
right from the very beginning of the
search we had deployed an aircraft as
well as a Navy vessel to ensure that
Canada was doing whatever it could
together with the United States and
others to assist in the time of need but
of course that investigation is ongoing
of course the investigation goes on and
how important is it to try and get to
the bottom of what happened I guess to
either find out if there is anyone or
anything to blame and also to stop it
happening again of course as the
investigation proceeds it would be
premature for me to make those types of
comments or hypotheses but I will say
that Canada from a domestic standpoint
will always be there to assist when
others have needs whether it is
domestically as we fight forest fires at
home or whether it is internationally
and collaborating with our allies in the
evacuation of Sudan or anywhere else and
that's exactly what we're seeing around
the aid for Ukraine and one of the
things I'm going to be doing tomorrow is
visiting Camp lid where Canadian Armed
Forces members together with other
countries including the UK are training
Ukrainian new recruits that's the type
of collaboration that Canada will bring
to the table regardless of the issue
okay thank you thank you so much
at my interview there with Canada's
defense minister Anita Anand on the show
a little earlier well busy quite varied
a program everything from the race to be
the Conservative candidate for London
mayor that I have to say now is looking
pretty tough for the conservative party
and of course at the cost of living
crisis that won't go away in the
spotlight right now the water companies
that's the issue the problem though and
the solution to the problem still feels
a little bit far away that's it for the
take this week we'll be back next week
on Wednesday up next it is Sky News at
10 for watching
[Music]